Glazkov: So I'm, um,
[coughs]
I'm Dimitri Glazkov.
I've been preparing this
all night.
And I hope this works.
And actually I decided
to do slides
about 30 minutes ago.
Because I didn't think
that all of this
can be explained with
enough love and care
by just using, you know,
shooting from the hip.
So basically there you go.
This is a WebKit.
It's a rendering engine
that we use.
Obviously
who doesn't know that?
You're probably
in the wrong spot.
Um, and it's a fairly, um,
um, complex piece of code.
And basically
it has the structure
is there's a WebCore
which is where the majority
of rendering occurs.
And then there's JavaScriptCore
which we don't use.
And in JavaScriptCore
there is a subproject,
or a subset of classes
that's called wtf.
man: Yes, really.
Glazkov: Yes, that's really
how it's called.
And it's a WebCore-type
foundation.
Or WebKit-type foundation.
And then there's some threading
stuff there
because that was the easiest
place to stick it into.
So you will find some
really interesting nuggets
of information like this
as you start studying the code.
What am I looking at?
Should be looking
at everybody.
And so WebCore is where
most of the magic is.
And then there's WebKit
which is essentially
the glue layer
or the actual port
of WebCore.
And there's one for Mac,
there's one for Qt.
There's one for Chromium
coming soon.
And Darin is working on that.
Where's Darin?
Did he leave?
man: He left.
Glazkov: Now I can bad-mouth
him all I want.
So the directory structure
is also fairly--
if you look at the WebCore
it's fairly straight forward.
Pretty much all the naming
convention
has now been made
pretty much logical.
You can kind of understand
what's going on.
Like bindings for example
is where all of the bindings
to JavaScript engines
or objective c live.
Dom deals with dom.
Css deals with css.
And so on and so forth.
And so what we do
is we--we now have
a formal--
we have a foothold
in WebKit upstream.
And this is our port
which is basically
the chromium port.
You will see a bunch
of directories.
Like there's one
for platform chromium.
There's one for graphics
and skier related things.
There's Google URL
that we implement very nicely.
V8 obviously.
And so this looks
really, really cool
except have you guys seen--
Who hasn't seen The Matrix?
Okay.
You haven't seen The Matrix?
Okay, then this is gonna be
completely irrelevant for you.
Have you guys seen one
of those famous action shots
where Keanu Reeves is, like,
you know, dodging bullets
and he's, like, standing
that way?
And if you were to be
introduced to Keanu
at this particular moment
in time,
you'd have a very uncomfortable
impression of Keanu
because the guy basically
walks like this.
And so this is exactly the
impression that you would get
if you look at our port
right now
because we are in transition
and so there's a bunch
of things that are supposed
to be in the right spot
but they're not.
And so we're still moving.
And so when you go look
at for example v8 bindings,
you'd find that some v8 bindings
live in upstream proper
and some of them live
in source WebKit port
bindings v8.
That's not because
we're so smart.
That's because we are
still working on it.
And so a lot of people
get--
I actually was asked
today at lunch
is like, "Why is some files
are there?
Why couldn't you just
move them there?"
We're working on it right now.
Okay, so this is
a resource constraint.
This is not a matter of us
picking and choosing
what things we want to keep
downstream and upstream.
It's all going
to move upstream one day
sooner--sooner or later.
Hopefully sooner.
And so we also have now
our own WebKit port
which Darin has birthed
and now he escaped
so that he doesn't have
to listen about it.
But it lives downstream
unfortunately
because it's very hard
to kind of jiggle
the wires very quickly
and adjust it
if some breakage occurs.
And so we build it
downstream
and then we're gonna move it
upstream wholesale.
Hopefully.
And so one of the please that
I have to you, WebKit newbies,
whoever you are,
is if you want to learn WebKit,
please help upstreaming.
So any, um--
any, um--
Anybody who has extra cycles
or is very actively interested
in learning WebKit,
the bindings for example,
please help upstreaming.
What it involves is essentially
grabbing a piece of v8 code--
v8 bindings code--
and make it conform
to WebKit code style,
submitting it as a patch
upstream,
getting it landed.
And then you'll feel
really, really good, so...
man: [unintelligible]
Glazkov: Yes, and all
these patches count
to your WebKit commuter access.
Exactly.
So this is all really helpful
it you want to be like
a commuter for example.
And, oh, by the way,
it's not really that much fun
because sometime you have
to go through
three or four rounds
of iterations
based mostly on nitpicking
and style
and style violations.
So it's sometimes very,
very frustrating.
But it teaches you patience,
right?
This is the most exciting thing
that you can learn.
Or if you have, like, a kit,
you're done.
You can do it very easily.
Um, so, um--
We're also in this continuous
effort of trying to unfork
and move ourselves out
of the situation
where we actually are
a fork or bender branch
um, of WebKit.
And this is a very--
very, um, hard work
and we actually track it
right here.
As you can see,
this is our current state.
Just this Monday,
the count was down to 15.
And thanks to a merge
that I did on Monday afternoon,
it's back to 34.
Because unfortunately sometimes
the changes made upstream
necessitate a fork
in our, um, in our port.
And now I have to go and work
to remove that fork
which really sucks.
But unfortunately
that's what it is.
So we have now removed--
not physically,
but we removed commit access
to the third party WebKit
so we try not to commit there
at all.
Unless this is like
a super-duper regression
that blocks us from releasing
a div branch
or div build for example.
And there's a daily merge.
So, um, every day somebody,
some unnamed hero,
takes the changes from upstream
and plops them down
onto our fork
and it's sometimes a really
hard process
and hair-pulling process
of figuring out what just
happened
because 100 layout tests just
started failing for no reason.
And so or you need
to start forking things.
But if you really want
to learn WebKit,
this is, like, the best way.
Because you will daily touch
various parts of code.
And you will have to study
and figure out what's wrong.
So this is how I learned WebKit
and I highly recommend it
to anybody...
um, who wants to be it.
So currently the rotation
is fixed.
But, Ian, aren't you working
to make everybody
a WebKit merger?
This is gonna be so great.
It's just like a sheriff.
Everybody will get to merge.
Hopefully we'll unfork by then,
but maybe not.
So, um, now I'm gonna talk
about Toolset.
What we're gonna do for
if you want to work on, um,
WebKit and that's very simple.
Just use Git and you're done.
Um, well actually
it's not that simple.
But one of the things
you have to learn,
if you're planning to work
on WebKit,
forget your Windows machine,
okay.
Working on WebKit upstream
on Windows
is so hard that most of us
have given up.
Peter: By the way,
I still do this.
And I think it's fine.
So if you want to do this,
you can ask me.
Glazkov: If you're Peter,
you can still use Windows.
But Ojohn can tell you that,
um,
none of us, and I repeat--
even you, Peter,
none of us have been able
to successfully run
WebKit layout tests
from upstream and succeed.
Because that requires pulling
down all of the Mac fonts
onto a Windows box,
configuring your clear type
just the right way,
and all the just weirdness
that comes with it.
So it's really--
it's really painful.
So if you want to work
with WebKit upstream,
this is your great excuse
to get a Mac,
if you want one.
If you don't want when,
then you know,
I can't help you, buddy.
So using Git is really,
really helpful.
I have it set up.
Can you guys see it okay?
So I'll show you just
a couple of things
in terms of Git.
It's very helpful because
it facilitates
a much better workflow.
Just like on any other product
or perhaps more,
in WebKit you will often
be having
several patches in flight
while they're waiting review.
And these patches will have
to be caressed and loved
a couple of times.
And so you have to tweak them.
So having multiple checkouts
in svn repository
is just--is just wrong.
So I highly recommend using--
using like a Git for multiple
branch work flow
where you can have multiple
branches in flight
and then rebase.
So I'll do a quick demo
if it works, right?
Ooh.
So for example I'm--
WebKit comes with some really--
Git comes with some
really cool stuff
like, um, shell completion.
So for example I have it
configured
so it always shows me
the current branch I'm on.
Which is land which this
is the branch I use
to land somebody else's patches.
And so, um,
I can see that there's nothing
going on
on this branch right now.
Whoo.
Back.
It's really fast.
And then I can go
to master branch.
And, uh...
It's usually much faster.
I promise.
Let me plug into power.
Ah, that's okay.
So then I do a Git pull
for example
and pull all of the changes
from the, um,
from my...
from upstream from
the master branch.
Downstream--there it is.
It's happening actually.
All right.
This shows me what changes
have been made.
Really nice.
Everything's pretty.
Uh-huh.
And then I can say Git
rebase master land
for example.
And what this does
is it lifts up
any divs or patches
that I might have
on land branch,
applies the changes
that I just pulled
and then attempts
to land or to apply
the patches that I have
onto this branch back.
And it's a really cool process
of um, um, kind of a, um,
patch-based scm.
So I really recommend it
pretty much for anybody
working on, um, on WebKit.
And like for example,
one of the things you would see
is I have multiple branches
right there
and, uh, pretty much like
I have three inspector changes
going on at the same time.
Because sometimes reviewers
take a while to do it.
To go through the process.
And sometimes I need to modify
and in order to keep sanity,
I have multiple branches.
And so I could work
on any of this
separately and then commit
a rebase.
For more information,
check with Evan.
And he has a--I think
we've taped it, right.
There is a Git talk
that you can go look at.
It's really--it's really great.
One of the things that
is really good
about WebKit is they have
integrated really well
with, uh, with Git.
So their prepare change log
script works with Git,
and their result change
log script work with Git
and so svn applied
works with Git.
So all of these tools
that they have,
all of the toolset
is in place.
And so I highly recommend
using it
because it keeps your sanity
in terms of maintaining
multiple patches in flight.
And shell completion.
So if you're ever applying
a patch,
uh, to WebKit,
I highly recommend using
svn-apply
because it does a lot more
smart things
than, um, than a normal patch.
And it's just wonderful.
Like for example if you're
applying your old patch
with a change log entry in it,
it will automatically put it
on top of the change log
and change the date
to today's date.
So it's beautiful,
it's gorgeous.
And so I highly recommend
using it.
And of course the whole
collection of scripts there
that you might look at.
Highly recommend looking
at them
because I use only three.
But there's more
and you probably could,
you know, benefit from them
in some way.
And trac.webkit.org/browser.
Very helpful tool.
Obviously anybody who used
Trac before
will be familiar with it.
But it allows you to go
look at the code
and browse it online.
It's much better than view,
uh, vc--
whatever that thing we have.
So if there are any fanatics
of uvc,
please, I don't mean it.
Um...
any questions on Git
or anything?
Anything I need to pause on?
No?
Okay.
Yes.
man: [inaudible]
Glazkov: Okay.
Git acts as a really good tool
if you're using--
if you're on a Mac.
I've never used it
but I heard it's good.
Um, actually Jeremy there
who makes suggestions,
he's the one who evangelized
me on Git.
And so I owe him a lot.
WebKit testing.
How do we test whether
WebKit is good or not,
whether a specific
variation is good or not?
Well, the primary test tool,
the vehicle that they have
upstream is layout tests.
And you guys are probably
all familiar
with what layout tests are.
It's several thousand
HTML files,
sometimes SVG,
sometimes, um, XML files
that you load in the browser
and basically look
for a specific behavior.
And all of this has been
automated.
Downstream we have test drill
that allows us to run
the tests.
Upstream it's called
dump render tree.
Highly misnamed,
but you know.
I recommended that they
rename it to test drill.
They have seemed to be resistant
for some reason.
And so--and basically
it's really not a very good
testing methodology
but that's what we have.
Having a unit test
or more extensive methodology
would probably--
at this point I don't think
it's really feasible.
So we're going with layout
tests.
And layout tests are born how?
Anytime you find a regression,
whenever you fix a bug,
you submit a layout test
with it
to make sure that this bug
is now covered.
And so this is how
you obtain coverage.
Instead of forward thinking,
you're kind of reacting.
And...and also there's
a couple of test suites.
W3c suite,
Hicksy's svg suite.
Batik svg--
a bunch of them.
Css suite.
Um, but, um,
those rarely ever fail because
they're kind of,
you know, simple.
Not that complicated.
Not that big of an edge case.
And the obviously we have
reliability tests.
Chromebot gives us crashes,
which is really great.
And that's something they don't
have downstream,
so if you're ever in builder--
By the way, I'm a sheriff today.
Let's see how we're doing.
Tree's open.
I don't know if that's because
it's actually open.
It's okay.
Or if it's because I'm missing.
Nobody closed the tree
for good reason.
[laughs]
So there are
reliability tests.
Is that it?
No.
That's a really nice bot.
This is your really good
indicator
of something--
ooh, look at that.
So you would see
that something happened.
For example we have
new crashes.
And reliability test
uses Chromebot, right?
Somebody correct me or not.
All right, it's the same
infrastructure.
And it just is a really
convenient way
for you to quickly see
what happened.
And so you can look
at the stack traces.
This is something the Mac
people--
or not Mac people--
what Git upstream does not have.
So we benefit from this because
we can discover things
that they cannot see.
So anyway.
We usually share
those results gladly
because we need to fix them
as well.
And performance tests,
obviously.
Who has not seen
performance tests here?
Do I need to go?
Look, you guys are fine.
Okay.
Let me look.
Oh.
Prf?
Click on prf.
I clicked on prf.
So you can see very quickly
how each commit reflects.
See how great we're doing.
We have just recently
implemented
TCMalloc allocator.
So this brought down
all of our numbers.
And then we have fixed
a major--
well not major,
but a bug in v8.
So this really shows us.
And when it goes
the opposite way,
then you're in trouble.
You have to fix it.
Peter usually comes
and bugs you
because he really watches
those things.
Well, he come and bug me.
Oh.
So this is real useful
because it allows you to see,
um, um, what's going on.
Page cycler--
anybody knows what
page cycler is.
Has this been covered earlier?
Have you guys been talking?
Wow, so this is a huge omission
obviously.
Um...um...
So page cyclers
are really cool things
that essentially it's a bunch
of HTML pages
that we run in succession.
And, um, then track
the time memory,
virtual bites used,
and things like that.
And so it allows us
to quickly measure
if something's changed.
So if there's a regression
then we have to go
and look at specific versions.
Like for example, ooh,
this is a regression
right here.
Let's see what changed it.
Crap!
[laughs]
My name on it.
This is just expectations.
So there you go.
Externalized strings
but not results, blah blah blah.
Non strings.
So something--you have to look--
oh, and me too.
Well anyway,
so any regressions you can
clearly see
what changes caused it.
You can see what kind
of regression that is
by clicking shift.
Shift.
Um, no.
Come on.
All right, so apparently Safari
doesn't do that.
But you usually can shift click
and you can then track down
and see what percentage
of regression that is...
And you can see specific
revisions
that caused the failure.
And then what is
the orange line?
That's the reference build.
What a reference build is
is that at some point in time
we took our build that we had
at the time
and put it in a separate
directory
and now we run it
every time we run
the reliability test
so that we know
that any fluctuation
in the tests are not caused
by some hardware changes
or the machine fell ill.
You can see that if
the ref has not changed
but the, um, blue line
has changed,
that means that it's really
a regression.
Sometimes you would go
in the morning
and you will see all of them
go down
because Nikolai has rebooted
the machine
and suddenly it runs faster.
But if both of them go
at the same distance,
you probably go, "Wow, that's
really not a regression
or anything."
So that's what reference build
is for.
That's a great explanation.
Sorry if I'm fumbling.
But anyway, this is how
you usually look at WebKit
and see what you've done.
If you're merging, this is one
of the greatest things
to watch for because even though
your layout tests
may be passing,
Dave Hyatt upstream may've
introduced some new code
that tremendously affects
painting for example.
And you will see regressions,
especially during HTML
[indistinct]
cycler that affects--that
involves a lot of repainting.
So you can clearly see
that, oh, something happened.
These 50 revisions of WebKit
caused us to regress 30%.
Roll back.
We usually just go
and look and see.
One of the interesting things
is with sheriffing,
the sheriffs typically don't
roll back the merge.
So if a specific individual
changed may be rolled back
but merge is really rolled back.
So it may seem like
a good thing,
but actually it's a bad thing
because
it puts pressure on you
as a merger
to go and fix the regression
rather than--
because nobody wants
your regression,
and yet you must go on.
So it's--there you go.
Uh, here's a simple sample.
Simple sample.
Bug-fix workflow for WebKit.
Suppose you're fixing
a WebKit bug.
This illustrates how inefficient
our system is
and how much we need
to unfork.
So typically the way you do it
is like this.
You get your bug fixed locally.
Reviewed in LGTM.
Then take that patch,
apply it to WebKit tree.
Prepare patch.
Then get it reviewed
on WebKit.
And then submit for review--
then--then commit
if you have a commit access.
Couple things to mention
is that
the etiquette of bugzilla
is that when you attach
a patch,
don't designate
a specific person.
Like, you know,
"Oh, Darin is a reviewer.
I'm gonna ask him to review it."
This is considered like
a faux pas
from the WebKit perspective.
They get angry with us
for some reason.
So instead I suggest highly
to just CC Darin.
And he will know.
Stamped to review.
So anyway, blah.
Are we recording this?
Scratch that.
[laughs]
So, um...
one of the hardest things
by far in WebKit
is code style.
It's different.
It's very different.
Like there is no edit lines.
The braces for methods
go on the new line.
Four characters--four spaces
rather than two spaces.
Lots of stuff like this.
Naming members,
variables.
And believe it or not,
for Googlers,
that was the hardest part.
That always is.
Because most of the time
your review comes back negative
only because of, you know,
the style violations.
So if you've never written
C++ code before,
you're in luck.
You could learn this.
If you've been a Googler
for five years,
you're screwed.
Um, I have five minutes
so I'm gonna rush.
So if you want to talk
to the browser
in your new code
like you're writing
web sockets
or something like this,
you need to use ChromiumBridge
or the new WebKit API
that Darin is cooking currently.
Since it's in progress
you need to talk to him
before doing anything.
Before even considering
design decisions
because he's the right guy
to discuss these things.
Um, now, when you--
if you're considering
making changes to WebKit,
try to put your WebKit hat on
and think about it this way.
This is not
a Chromium-specific change.
This is change that should
benefit WebKit as a whole.
So try to avoid making changes
that are just for benefit
of WebKit.
So if you're writing web sockets
or a new functionality
like html five forms,
think of it as this--
"I'm implementing it
for WebKit, not for Chromium."
Does that make sense?
And obviously be aware
of other ports.
So try not to break Qt
or some other obscure ports
that are on the build bot.
Becoming a committer
is an easy task.
It's just ten patches.
And it's something
you definitely
should consider doing.
It's very easy.
A couple of upstreaming patches,
a couple of bug-fixes,
you're there.
WebKit prides itself
on communication
so stay open,
participate.
You guys in Japan
still might consider
going on WebKit,
you'll be surprised
that you'll find Apple engineers
working at that time
because they're really,
really weird hours.
I mean, it's just unbelievable.
And so any proposals,
any ideas?
Highly recommend to circulate
on webkit-dev
unless it involves
forking code.
In which case I highly recommend
talking to Ian first.
And he will triage it
from there.
And so...
there you go.
Any questions or comments?
Done!
[applause]